when i lived in queens
i went to the beauty parlor every two
weeks
i still do it here in this independent
living community
it's the same routine
this routine
is my life i have been used to it ever
since i came to america
look i'm 91 years old and i can't stop
the aging process but i try
to remedy whatever i can
if you want to call it a beauty routine
say i don't i call it just taking care
of yourself
i do it as part of my living
i don't think i feel beautiful i feel
like
i'm thelma
[Music]
change is hard
change is hard at any age
but being a senior and leaving your home
and leaving familiar
faces and starting new
routines important
so if they're in the habit of getting
their hair done on a friday at one
o'clock they still want friday at one
o'clock
i'm renee carpenido i'm the salon
coordinator and hair stylist at
riverwalk salon
i've been here for 14 years
and working in a residence like this it
does give you enjoyment being with them
it makes them feel good because that's
what they're supposed to be doing
they've been through it all doing their
hair making them pretty and making them
feel good you also help them get through
their day a little easier
[Music]
i was born in 1927.
i was a teenager during the holocaust in
france
there were days when you couldn't take a
bath because there was nothing
but during the war i had
one lipstick and i remember it was
called rouge beze which means red kiss
lipstick made me feel beautiful
so it's important to me to keep myself
clean
and to keep myself
looking the best i can
we came to this country after the war in
1947
i met my husband i was married 65 years
after my husband died i felt very lonely
and i was in terrible shape when i came
here
but the beauty salon is downstairs on
the lower floor morning i go to the
beauty parlor every two weeks
it's an intimate place i talk to people
you feel very good going there
i know that i'll come out and i look
decent
two years ago my husband fell and died
i never thought that this would happen
to me
at the beginning i froze
and i said who am i
always dressed see this is the way my
family was we always dressed
this is my life today it cannot be
what it was
i have to maintain
who i am
i love clothes
my hair is the same as it was when i was
20
it's very simple and i don't want to
lose myself
so far i have not
delma's been here a little while good
morning
she's very sharp
she's very into fashion delma has her
style she knows what she likes i'm not
too sure
and i do what she likes week after week
she shares a lot of stories and she goes
out often and you know she's just living
life and enjoying life
i feel like coming here gives me the
opportunity to have 95 grandmothers
it's a very comfortable place to be
they're getting older and their life is
getting a little harder so when you're
the one that makes their day better
that gives you so much more fulfillment
[Music]
you